now they then saying this this requires
a bit of thought they then say hence
show that the seventh coefficient is the
greatest one how many coefficients are
they going to be in this expansion Billy
they will be 13 right there will be the
12 and then the 0th one which is 13 of
them so of the 13 coefficients the
seventh one is that the middle one I
think in this case it actually is right
and why is that well this two and this
three they're not very different
did you notice up here I had to make
these numbers quite different in order
to change where the greatest coefficient
will be so this is kind of nice it's
still going to be in the middle but how
do I show that it will be in the middle
well I need a bit more space to show
this but let me see what will I wipe off
then I write all of these ok I need to
point at something up here you've
already got this and you're working I
want to point it out and then I'm going
to I'm gonna rub it off so that we can
actually do the working okay I want you
to have a look at the coefficients the
the T sub KS for all of these okay so
pay close attention to the document
because the piece of logic that you need
is very simple but if you don't get it
then the next is just going to be
algebra suit for no reason
okay so what I want you to observe is
one way of working out the greatest
coefficient is just to work out all the
coefficients right if you work them all
out then you can clearly see oh that's
the biggest one right that's the biggest
one and then you can just eyeball it and
say I know which one it is okay but we
know how tremendously inefficient
without even starting we know that's not
a good idea if you've got lots and lots
of terms this is going to be a very
time-consuming way to go about these
okay so what would be a way of be able
to work out faster that that one of them
is the biggest one okay well do you
notice right let's have a look at the
original situation they get bigger and
bigger and bigger you you hit your
maximum right and then after that they
get smaller and smaller just just make
sense
in fact even for these two where I've
changed where the greatest coefficient
happens this still occurs right they get
bigger and bigger until you hit a
maximum and then after that smaller
smaller smaller
you hit the biggest one straight away
and then they subsequently get smaller
okay so in other words what I want is I
want to find out at some point well from
the start as you advance to the next
term you will be bigger than the
previous term right for example here if
we call this this is T 0 T 1 T 2 T 3 T 4
okay I can write of this first liner
maybe you want to write this with me as
well right for this first line I can say
T 0 is smaller than T 1 and that's
smaller than T 2 but then at that point
right this is T 2 right in the middle I
know it's a bit funny because you start
counting from zero right but that's the
T 2 after that it doesn't get bigger
anymore so T 2 is bigger than T 3 which
is bigger than T 4 does this make sense
right in this case here T 0 is smaller
than T 1 you get bigger but then after
that it just gets smaller and smaller
and smaller this makes sense and you
don't need me to write this 1 T 0 will
be the very biggest one and everything
else is smaller okay so what I'm trying
to find is if I can say this right it's
for many values of K this will be true
but at a certain value of K it stops
right the next term is no longer bigger
than the term before it and once you hit
that point if you can solve this then
you have found the greatest coefficient
does that make sense if I can find all
the places where this is true then that
means the next one would be bigger the
next one bigger the next one bigger if
it is not true you're no longer getting
bigger you've passed the greatest
coefficient does that make sense so this
is the thing I want to solve this is the
inequality right now can you see why
therefore we spent Part A finding
expressions for this and this right
because these are going to feed into my
inequality okay
now the last thing I want to point out
is before we actually start to do this
have a look at T sub K and T sub K plus
1 okay I just have a look at those
expressions
because they were built off of the same
it's the this formula up here this one
right do you see how much they have in
common they have a lot in common right
for example the 12 factorials they're
just identical right these factorials
down the bottom they are very very
similar to each other they're only off
by one like these guys right and then
these two bits on the end here write the
number of twos and the number of threes
they are very similar again they are
only off by one okay so while I could
solve this it might make a little more
sense to solve this just think about
this with me okay if you look at these
two guys here do you agree that they are
equivalent inequalities that's a weird
phrase to say equivalent inequalities
you're solving the same thing here right
assuming that we're working with
positive coefficients now the reason why
I like this better than this it's a bit
weird we usually try to avoid fractions
don't we we usually say as soon as you
go as soon as you treat see fractions
multiply through by something to get rid
of them
okay can anyone tell me why looking at
these two disastrous looking things why
my fractions be a really really good
idea have a think so here's T K plus 1
he is take hey I'm saying put this on
the top put this on the bottom if you
divide this sorry if you divide this by
this you're going to have a lot of kids
late right like every single term that
you've written will have some form of
Catholic for instance this 12 factorial
in this 12 factorial what's going to
happen to them just gone immediately
right have a look at this K plus 1
factorial and this K factorial out of
these two you're dividing this one this
would be on the numerator this would be
able to denominator right one of them is
going to completely vanish which one
this one this one is smaller yeah so all
of these will go and all you'll be left
with is the very last term in this
factorial just the k plus 1 part right
so you can see you can match up this guy
with this guy you can match up these two
you can match up these two you can
everything okay so this is what I'm
going to try and find I'm going to find
the expression for that it's gonna take
a bit of work to write it the first time
but then once I do I can just go to town
canceling everything and I'll come up
with something quite nice and neat okay
and you can see that's what we've got
over there in the question so I need to
wipe things off but what I want you to
do is write down this this this fraction
here okay and then just begin to
substitute this whole thing and this
whole thing in the numerator in the
denominator and then we're gonna start
canceling together you've got to be
quite careful when you do it okay so
begin by writing that while I make
myself some space so what am i written
down well here's T of K plus 1 right
down here and here is T of K rather than
write fractions on fractions because it
will become quite messy I've just
written this divided by that okay so
I've got big fat division side so I
don't mistake it for a subtraction sign
and then I want you to have a look
you'll notice that I have underlined a
few terms and I've unlike some very
specific ones okay firstly before I
explain that you'll notice that the 12
factorial here over 12 factor oh here
they just kind of disappear in my next
line you okay with that I'm just gonna
cancel them straight out okay but now I
want you to notice why I've underlined
these four terms in particular remember
I mentioned that everything is going to
pair up so you've got after your 12
factorials are done okay you've got one
two three four terms on the left that
are going to match up with one two three
four terms on the right okay but what
I've underlined in each case is that
depending on which term you're looking
at one of the terms will be bigger let
me say that again right depending on
which terms you are matching up one of
the terms in the pair will always be
bigger than the other one okay so for
example if we go through this in order
right you've got two to the power of 11
minus K and what it matches up with is
two to the power of 12 minus K now which
one of those is bigger well this one is
bigger because there are twelve lots of
two being multiplied this one only has
11 okay so therefore all of these terms
every single one of the twos in here
however many there are they will all
disappear in a min
they will all be canceled out how many
will be left over here exactly one okay
if you have a look at the same way over
here and here these are the threes and
they are gonna pair up which one of them
is bigger well this one is bigger
because it has exactly one more three
than this guy does this make sense so
what I'm gonna encourage you to do is to
do this same kind of like highlight for
yourself where am I going to have the
terms that are remaining because
everything else is going to cancel out
right so now I'm going to begin you can
see that I've already I'm not gonna
write my 12 factorial okay I I see here
right out of these two terms here's a
big fraction divided here's a big
fraction this one is all going to
disappear which leaves me just with two
from there sound makes sense like
everything else from the twos will go
okay then I I progressed over without
the threes well all of these threes will
cancel leaving you with just one three
over here
that makes sense so I'm just gonna write
three I've done with my numerator see it
looks bad but if you patiently go
through it and use some color to help
yourself it's not that hard to work out
what's what this k plus one factorial
it's going to cancel because bigger than
this one with almost with every term
from here but what will be left behind
just that the biggest part which is just
K plus one and then you finish out over
here because all of these terms from
this factorial will disappear only
leaving you with the biggest term from
this one what is the biggest term in
this whole factorial it's gonna be the
last term along right 12 minus K so I'm
gonna write 12 minus K there you go
looked like a bit of a dog's breakfast
when we started right but the point of
dividing B's B's because we know in
advance they will cancel out and leave
us with something neat okay so now that
I've actually done my kid something I'm
going to you know multiply take the
reciprocal you can see I end up with
this and this look at the question does
that look familiar to you
are you happy so in a large number of
cases they will give you this result
because they really
want you to get to the next part but
sometimes they won't and it's up to you
to be able to work out this part on your
own so you have to be quite careful with
the way that you set your algebra okay